you once said there would never be a
wiser King than me you were wrong the
alignment has brought all the Realms
together every one of them saw you offer
your life to save them what can Asgard
offer its new King in
return my
life father I cannot be king of
Asgard I will protect Asgard in all the
Realms with my last in every breath but
I cannot do so from that shair Loki for
all his grave imbalance understood ruers
I know I never will the brutality the
sacrifice it changes you I'd rather be a
good man than a great
king is this my son I hear or the woman
he loves when you speak to I never hear
mother's
voice this is not for Jane for father
she does not know what I came here to
say now forbid me to see her or say she
can rule on my side it changes
nothing one son who wanted the throne
too
much another who will not take it is
this my legacy Loki died with
honor I shall try to live the same is
that not legacy
enough
it belongs to
you if you are worthy of it I shall try
to
be I cannot give you my
blessing nor can I wish you good
fortune an
know if I were proud of the man my son
had
become even that I could not
say
it would speak only from my
heart
go my
son thank you
[Music]
Father
no thank
[Music]
you